one when they were asking you to do like  the doc the animal documentary thing and  then you started sounding like the  narrator like David  from Sherman Oaks the Wilds of Sherman  Oaks and deal with 101 traffic very bad  around the downtown area to see the  local  angelinos in mating season on the side  of the room how is that coming out of it  that's great  I don't know what it is about that voice  but uh there's just that sounds like  your real voice now you're [ __ ]  around yeah this is this is fake why are  you [ __ ] around right now man we're  here in Monterey Park  known for its Boba  you cannot drive five feet in this area  without seeing a boba sign yeah I don't  know very good it's very it's very oh  thanks guys insane